there are things I can't say just
because it's not like
so you look at a funny one what's your
best party trick that's like a frog you
should have done that even more I feel
like I hurt my what was something you
saw as a failure at the time and now you
see as a lesson
I like daydream a lot so I really think
about the future of like okay this is
gonna happen and this is gonna happen
this is gonna happen and like boom and
then it just never does well in what was
the most pivotal moment that got you to
where you are today things I can't say
there are things I can't say just
because it's not like I don't know if I
can responsibly answer that yeah I don't
believe in some kind of life path that
somebody has or that you're destined to
be somewhere any I don't believe that
but I do believe that when you are being
exactly true to yourself certain things
that way that are just the most amazing
you know that that led me to start my
family led me to make very strong
decisions that would then that would
take my life into different directions
most awkward situation you've ever
visioned lord I can't talk about that
one either
what what qualities do you encourage in
your daughter's that really their mind
matters more than their outward
appearance kindness yes of course but
that they need to know themselves and
sharpen their mind and educate
themselves and really value the chance
that they get for an education because a
lot of girls don't how would you
describe yourself to someone
has never met or heard of you oh gosh
that's crazy I'll describe you okay I
mean you are much stronger than people
know
you're much more of an intellect and
you're much more like savvy and tough
than people now I like to keep it that
way where I like sugar on the outside
and like hard as nails I answer your
grateful I always noticed that about
yours very grateful for any kindness or
anything that you have first time yeah I
got it yeah she's pretty cool I like oh
we're attached we're tag
[Music]